let's keep taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 our next callers from the for 1 7
area code caller where are you calling
from and what's your name
I'm calling from Missouri my name is
Joseph great what's on your mind all I
just want to see if you need for her
dove or maybe if you cover in the future
a group we have here in Missouri called
government by the people you can look
that up I've never heard of it I've
never heard of it one whole type of
group is it oh well it's an effort to
change the country via the state
referendum process and change our state
constitution now some states allow their
the voters to change the state
constitution through a referendum
process Missouri is one of those states
that's where it's starting and they had
seven proposals including an instant
runoff proposal like what they had in
Maine one for a proportional legislature
green New Deal public option health
insurance and also a protection for for
referendum changes that were passed by
the voters so we don't have something
like I think it was North Dakota where
the legislature took back legislature
took back the a ballot initiative that
just were killed it that would protect
it from all hours or seven of them yeah
so what what's the date I mean is the
day-to-day of trying to do this is it a
lot of signature collection right now
its signature collection um getting
phone calls out like I just did this on
spur them I just recently started
associating with myself but most of it
right now is getting those signatures
out on the ballot and to get into
fissures to get on the ballot and then
getting it voted on of the seven
initiatives that you're currently
working on which is the one you think
most likely that you would be able to
get past a proportional legislature
people really are sick of gerrymandering
a secular two-party system and with this
you wouldn't have third parties you just
have parties and independence right and
there be no wasted votes and no
gerrymandering whatsoever
very interesting
interesting and you know I mean there's
there's connection between that in a
parliamentary system which is
fundamentally very different than what
we have in the u.s. in most states and
certainly at the federal level but it's
a it's a very interesting approach to
fixing the gerrymandering issues so very
interesting thanks for telling us about
it oh sure all right thank you very much
article